hello mr. Khan I felt you spoke really
truly inspiring Lee about valuing
creativity and about facing your fears
my concern is I feel there are many
students out there who are passionate
about creativity and are also generally
brave people who can face their fears
but in spite of this they choose safer
more traditional non creative paths in
life because they feel the creative path
is simply too risky no matter how brave
they are and even though they love
creativity for its own sake not for
bartering it for money they feel they'd
still need to be able to pay the bills
and that might not happen so for a
person who is devoted to the arts but
due to certain practical realities of
the world selects a non creative path is
it possible for such a person to lead a
truly happy fulfilling life on a
personal note I am really worried
because I'm a huge fan of creative
writing and I did a lot of that in
school and at college but now I've
chosen law school and I console myself
by saying so what if you're not writing
movies or TV shows you still be writing
legal briefs and legal memos and I think
you know while on some level that makes
sense I think it's an extremely
depressing thought and I do feel like
somebody's stepping on my oxygen tea but
I fear that the alternative might feel
like somebody simply cut off my oxygen
to you because I won't be able to pay my
bills
so my question really is and I asked
this on behalf of everyone like me can I
be happy and it's so hot
Nega let me tell you you've got problems
dude but I tell you how I've done it you
know I did theater and I truly believe
in being very creative very artistic and
a very serious actor at times I really
do when I see a lot of work that has
been done around by other actors in my
own country and outside
I feel envious at times that I've not
been able to do that because like you
said when I came on to Mumbai and I
would say this to all the kids that yes
surviving is the most that's what the
whole speech was that you have I'll
teach you how to survive you know I'm
not gonna give you any thoughts about
that listen it's alright to you know go
on top of em Elias and do your writing
creative writing whether anyone reads it
or not know it's important that people
read it it's important it becomes a
best-seller as a matter of fact I very
shamelessly say I am the most capitalist
human being that you will ever find on
the face of this earth I truly believe
that you need to find a place where you
can make the choices that you want to
make you cannot just say you know I had
a friend who was a creative writer and
who fortunately still is not a lawyer
and he wanted to write books and he's
working here in America New York
actually been and he asked me one day
his father died and he said you know I
want to write books I won't write
creative stuff on spirituality and
goodness and I don't want to like
anything else how am I gonna survive my
father's dead my mother's not being able
to look after me and I said you know you
go down and you know start working in a
advertising company where he started
writing I do remember you know we this
is a joke we had in college I don't know
if it is still here you know it was an
inner where and you know with a with a
you know like a Calvin Klein underwear
model and you write it's for everyone
every Tom Dick and Harry
and so which you say if you write this
stuff you write it and earn the money
payables don't let them cut your oxygen
to you about but after you are in that
position of choice don't misuse it and
that's the one thing that I was I
decided to do I do a lot of advertising
a lot of people question me on the
uncreated bits of work that I do I do I
think out of ten things that I do I
think seven of them are highly unclear
in highly uncreated and very disturbing
at times I have a big bathroom now I sit
there and cry after having done those
things I genuinely do I'm not lying I
want I want kids to know this that yeah
I do that I get I'm like I don't want to
do this but I take the money from that
and I would like to be able to create a
produce a production house a filmmaking
institution which would do the creative
stuff which I wanted to do when I was 25
it may get a little late it may happen
when I'm 50 or 55 may not have happened
when I dreamed off with a 2627 but I'm
sure that I will make the right choices
so please all your kids do not get
waylaid by anyone who tells you it's a
wonderful to be creative and poor and
hungry no you can't be that you have to
survive your parents you owe it to your
life be well have good cars have a good
television have three Playstations if
you need but when you get into that
position of choice make sure you don't
cheat with your choices